[Music]
we're gonna talk about IP addressing
today we don't have slides we wanted to
make this more of a conversation I will
warn you that I'm gonna ask you to raise
your hands a lot and I'm gonna ask you
to put your hands down a lot so if you
need to limber up a little bit before
hand you know get yourself get yourself
loose another thing is I might ask some
questions during the during the
conversation so if you're really eager
to ask a question just hustle off to one
of the mics I think we're only gonna
have time for maybe one question during
those times and we'll try and save a
little bit of time for questions at the
end but who knows if we'll actually have
that time so and please don't tackle
each other if you you know okay
so quick introductions my name is Jeremy
Johnson I'm a product manager on the
cloud networking team and with me today
I've got Patrick ancelotti from from
Vimeo and Patrick runs both security and
systems at Vimeo he's a VP of systems
and security and to his left we've got
Kyle Moscato he's the director of DevOps
and security for for bitly and pretty
much it's very similar very similar
roles runs all of systems and security
at Vimeo
all right part me at bitly and to his
left one of my colleagues Olivia Voltron
he is a product manager in the cloud
networking team as well and so with not
much further ado I'm gonna get started
so when we think about IP addressing in
the cloud one of the things that strikes
me often because this is my area of
focus is that the the last non-elastic
resource in cloud is the IP address
usually when you're out of IP addresses
you're out of IP addresses and it can
cause a real problem and so the this is
why we thought this would be a useful
conversation today because I think we
all struggle with some issues with IP
addresses we kind of break this down
into two into two categories sort of
public IP addresses so
he addresses that have access to the
internet and private IP addresses
generally RFC 1918 space so we're gonna
start by talking about how we think
about private address space and you know
I talked to Patrick quite a bit about
this and Patrick's got a pretty unique
viewpoint on on the differences between
private and public IP addresses or the
lack thereof so I'll just hand it over
to Patrick Merritt I gotta hear me so
I'm assuming Janine wondering one of the
things that's a little different about
the way we treat IP addressing is
there's no to us functionally there's no
difference between a private and a
public address like the public addresses
face the there is a technological
difference but we we don't inherently
trust any network so for us it's about
explicit instead of implicit security we
we go out of our way to make sure that
even if something is talking over the
Internet there's encryption there is
explicit firewall rules that allow this
thing to talk to this thing instead of
saying this network that we trust is
secure is able to talk to us and so we
spend a lot of time thinking about if
any of you've watched an either but
beyond Corp talks think about it like a
be on Corp style behavior for a network
security in the cloud the Google behaves
this way internally - there's no Google
service that talks to another Google
service even over a Google network that
is unencrypted and isn't explicitly
allowed to do so yeah and I think Kyle
has a has a slightly different viewpoint
on this yeah our peravaram it's a little
less complicated than the Vimeo
environment so we take a much more
simple approach to running a single V PC
we use our IP address range on the
private space in full RFC and we have to
map and balance that across our on-prem
solutions across direct interconnect and
our public IP address concerns only real
all revolve around a single Class C that
is the root of all of the problems that
we face if Italy from a public
perspective and we'll get into more that
later but we keep it an implicit trust
within our V
see so if you're in our VPC you have a
trust with some obvious basic firewall
rules to talk to just about anything
else so it simplifies our CI CD pipeline
and other things yeah we have really fun
bow down here i mean so on vimeo side
there's no trust inside inside v pc
right explicit security for your sleep
you need vm inside the policy and in bit
aside i meet up first which is a vp c
and inside this limit of trust
I mean everybody everything I connect
everything right yes the moment aspects
but yeah everything connect everything
we put a lot of our security focus at
the border and then inside we we
realized that if you've already broken
in the door they're like you're gonna
get around for now yeah so when we
design a solution for a good cloud in
our mind the V PC is the limit of trust
and we have we designed to model for
team security so there's shared PC that
we introduced last year in shadow PC if
you have multiple teams all those teams
are going to be in one V PC you have a
centralized team doing the management
the security management for all those
teams so sick so centralized team of
network admin through the management for
all those teams but each team can be in
different project inside this V PC and
so have different I am or different
billing right the other model is 1 V PC
Tim and when you have 1 V PC protein
then each team will have different
network admin and different I am
different link with different security
rules and to connect them you can use V
PC peering that we introduced last year
as well you can use the VPN and you can
use VM mechanic you know also have a
built-in you can nvm I think you are
using V PC peering right yeah we're
using the PC peering we enabled it
pretty early on for some we're doing one
of I'm on my third cloud migration of
the last 18 months so
I've got a lot of gray hair now and a
lot sadder but during one of the
migrations we we take the stance that
each functional unit should have both a
development project and a production
project and one of the production
projects needed to speak private we
weren't able to add encryption to the
protocol so we we opted to use vpz
peering because it at least gave us some
[Music]
it moved us towards the aspiration of
everything needing to be encrypted so
with VPC peering there were a lot of
advantages but there were some hiccups
that we ended up bumping into which is
one of the we've built a tool or and I'm
solving some of these problems yeah so
this is where I'd like to ask the
audience some questions so how many
folks in the audience we've talked about
sort of the idea of implicit trust
versus explicit trust the implicit trust
model would really leverage that shared
VPC and host projects whereas the
whereas the explicit trust model might
prefer to use separate V PCs and V PC
peering or the multi NIC approach so how
many folks in here use use more of the
shared V PC model awesome that's it
looks like maybe about slightly less
than half of the room and how many how
many folks use you share B or use a
model where where you're using explicit
trust it's kind of not quite the rest so
I suggest better I yeah there are a
couple of both there there are some that
that didn't raise your hands so I
suspect those that didn't raise their
hands probably are using you know maybe
smaller deployments with a single
project alright let's move on so one of
the questions we also ask ourselves well
while we're designing these systems is
kind of why bother with IP addresses at
all this is obviously we need IP
addresses on the host but to make to
solve some of that elasticity problem
and some of the program programmability
problems that we have especially when
you have explicit rule sets to manage
you know it might it might make sense to
provide an abstraction a label a tag
something like that as opposed to just
an IP address
so we do support some of these concepts
in our in our cloud and so I'm gonna
hand it over the panel we're going to
talk about abstractions now I'll start
so one of the hardest documents that
we've ever tried to write Worley in our
first cloud migration we we have a data
center and the data center has static IP
addressing and we've got a we've got as
Jeremy calls that the the number one IP
management tool in the world Google
sheets and and we're we're updating the
sheet and we start doing the same in gke
because I'm not UK and GCP because well
like machines are going to be stateful
we're just doing in lift and shift and
then we're going to reorganize and after
a couple of weeks we start to notice
that no one's updating the IP address
management tool and things are starting
to appear in the environment but
nothing's overlapping because the IP
addresses are all it's an all enforced
and then we started to deploy gke and
everything became completely trashed so
GK is wonderful but if any of you have
ever deployed it every container gets an
IP there is no way you're gonna build
any sort of human involved IP address
management with that in mind and a lot
of the time we spent doing that was more
we kept trying to lift concepts from our
on-prem data centers and from our
offices and on-prem locations into the
cloud and being like this should just
sort of work and like we'll know better
we should have known better but slowly
but surely we realized like IP
addressing is not actually that
important to us it seems to only come up
for us when we want to overlap with
something that is in a physical space
and we've worked around it in other ways
my end goal is to never care about IP
addresses again we're actively involved
in a lift and shift of a lot of our
infrastructure into GCP right now and so
we have to use them we have to use IP
addresses for our firewall rules for our
ackles for the direct interconnects that
we have between data centers and GCP
that's a requirement because we're not
gonna get to go anywhere else and we're
not going to get any security unless we
do that but
as we're putting products inside of GCP
tags are pretty much becoming the best
thing under the Sun for us it's it's
logical it's easy scales really well you
don't have to touch it after a time and
I'm gonna throw a small softball
question over to you which is we had a
lot of trouble figuring this out the
beginning can you explain the functional
difference between tags labels and maybe
service accounts I think it's really so
there's a label tags and several seconds
right that are used to I mean to move IP
address or host sources together
labels are only used for billing so they
are not used at all for security or
networking so level only billing so for
security and coping mechanism for
networking
we have tags and service seconds so the
big difference between the two so
service icons is a bit more recent then
tags
I think tags was released two three
years ago I guess don't you like this
and semi second last year the big
difference is if four tags you can have
multiple tags per VM right for service
icons you can only have one service icon
per VM that's one limit the advantage of
service a condo is seen as a bit more
secure because service icons you can
design I am all to decide who can add
this service icon to this VM right so it
can be a bit more granular into who can
change all sappy seconds all for each VM
is that the big difference but it can be
used I mean they are used the same way
now used to group VM together for five
walls and stuff like this so just one
one one point on on getting rid of IP IP
addresses so I have a bit of an issue
with that
so I'm hearing a lot from customers
that's oh let's get rid of IP address
and this use label and and I want to
connect red with Roo
and but blue cannot be connected with
green let's let's get rid of IP
addresses and and use color or labor for
all of this that's to assure I see with
that and I would love to get your own
point of view on that the first one is
there's always a limit of trust
somewhere right so if it's if you manage
everything then it's very easy to color
you or sauce with those labels or with
those tags and so on but if you receive
routes from somebody else right you
cannot trust those labels right finally
if you'll receive BGP routes or if
you're doing peering and you're
receiving some some traffic from this
other network you cannot trust it right
so that's need to be a way to a policy
to map those labels to those IP address
so I so I don't see those appear as
disappearing if even if it would be a
nice goal and then and then can that
could be perhaps an implementation issue
so that's something we we could perhaps
find a workaround for that but just a
scaling issue in a sense that if you
have one label per VM and you have a
firewall rule for them basically you
have like one firewall
I mean you have if you have ten vm you
have ten firewall right in the
implementation this is real / 32 right
while IP addresses you can aggregate
them right you can do / 24 sep 21 whole
like map like 200 vm or something like
this so there's killing advantage also
in in IP addresses
so we need we need subnet masks for tags
yeah so from Google's approach for Samoa
or smaller management for Spooner
customer it might work better than for
larger deployments on falsehood so we
need to find a way to I mean to do use a
fixed beauty of tags and we have the
skinny yeah something sometime we use
internally at Google that that is is
also useful as sometimes we identify
things you think about what you use IP
addresses for use them to apply policy
you use them to secure to secure
communications between two entities but
you also use them for identification
that's primarily why they're used in gke
for example and one of the things we do
inside of Google is we actually use a
tuple that's the IP address and a
process ID and something that we would
probably extend to you know this kind of
pattern also works probably well with
the lower order bits on v6 we'll talk
about that in a minute before we before
we get into this really quick just a
poll of the crowd again so loosen up how
many how many of you folks are using
tags in your deployments today oh that's
great that's almost everybody how many
how many folks have used service
accounts in your deployments also a good
number that's that's almost all the room
that's great so by the way I'd encourage
you if we're talking about something
that you really want to talk about holla
walk up to the mic and ask a question I
think we're gonna we're gonna move on
into kind of so Patrick mentioned
something that's near and dear to my
heart which is which is the IP IP
address management yeah this is a
challenge that we all have and I think
that IP address managers were not built
for clouds masane IP anything about IP
wasn't really built for clouds right we
have we have overlapping namespaces we
have poorly coordinated deployments
where you know developer is and talking
to developer B and they both end up on
subnet a I mean this happens all the
time so how do we avoid these kinds of
things we
we really actually need a good a good IP
address management system that's really
built for built for cloud deployments
and so we have to move beyond
spreadsheets right so before before we
talked to the panel about this how many
of the folks in the in the crowd are
using spreadsheets to manage IP
addresses ok the honest ones that raise
their hands is about half the room and
how many how many folks in the room
actually have a have a commercial
off-the-shelf or home-built IPM solution
ok a little less than half so again
there's some people who just aren't
managing IP addresses in so those fools
that say that are using IPM who is using
those ipam to manage cloud our sources
there are only a handful yeah
yep yeah so subnets and I subnet sorry
and I pan but not managing individual IP
addresses this is exactly the point so
we're talking about this idea that IP
addresses in cloud are oftentimes
ephemeral especially as we move towards
micro-services right so what kind of
human driven I Pam you know kind of
helps with that so I'm gonna kick it to
the panel I get some thoughts on this so
I probably have to start with some
organizational stuff to explain how I
got to where I am we serve amia
practices engineering autonomy so if a
team would like to progress faster than
the rest of the organization can they
have the freedom to do so sometimes that
results in some stuff that wasn't
planned for but isn't the worst stuff
but also isn't the great greatest stuff
so we in our biggest production project
we use auto IP addressing is everyone
familiar with the when you create a
network it gives you a bunch of IP s and
they overlap everywhere all the time
and once production services are living
on a network that's where they will stay
until you die so we've in a lot of cases
we've ended up using order submitting
not because we planned it that way
because truthfully we didn't but because
the progress to the cloud happened
before we had infrastructure folk
involved earlier on which is the great a
great thing for the company and we we
still wholeheartedly encourage engineers
to move quickly but it's something that
it's really hard for us to undo and at
least I for one would love to have
something where I could add some we're
within GCP define available ranges and
allow networks to be created out of
those and reserve them sort of like an
AI pen but I I don't have any in
physical infrastructure anymore so it's
easy for me to say that without having
to worry about the unprimed stuff
anymore let me ask one question of the
crowd really quick it is is the
distinction between auto mode and custom
mode subnets
clear to everyone okay I see a few
shaking yes if you know so I'll just
explain you know at a high level really
quickly when you when you create a when
you create a subnet in a V PC you can
have a V PC in Auto mode in which case
every region will have its own its own
subnets just automatically allocated for
you the custom mode allows you to choose
your own range and and and set your own
subnet mask so the the thing that's
interesting about this is if you if
you've got you know developer autonomy
and the ability to build a V PC on your
own you might you might really like that
that auto mode because you know you
don't you don't really want to think
about IP addresses when you when you
build out your your project on the other
hand if you do have an IP address policy
right and you do have concerns about
talking to other other organizations
with your project etc then you need that
custom mode that the distinction is even
more important when you realize that in
order to convert from auto mode to
custom mode you have to drain the auto
mode VPC which means you kind of gotta
start over so it's it's one of those
choices that you make that has lasting
implications and I think that's what
Patrick's getting at they did a lot with
auto mode and they don't want to go
backwards right we're always moving
forward so hey
so naturally we started with auto mode
and then realized really quickly that it
of course overlapped with our private IP
address scheme that we had in our data
center so we had to start back over and
we also heard some great horror stories
from our product team and our Tam's
about why we shouldn't use auto mode
that was always fun to hear other
people's pain but as it comes to our
address management we were using
spreadsheets we're using Google sheets
to track our AP's right now and our hope
is that as we move forward we're not
gonna need to do that anymore and Jeremy
said IP addresses weren't really
designed for the cloud and I agree with
that and I think that if you're spinning
up thousands of containers every day
every hour there's no human readable
format that's going to be useful to you
right the only thing you can trust at
that point is what your API tells you is
- this microsecond or millisecond and
because of that like organizations and
process and policy has to change about
how you're choosing to manage those and
maybe ephemeral is not the right word
for how I think IP address management
has to happen in the future but it's
something near there it's um
you know the IP address becomes this
arbitrary thing that just exists in the
code for you and controls certain access
to certain thing and ideally you know in
a cloud environment that's
programmatically done through tags or
some other thing where you come in and
set that default lis so once you get we
are that we think is a typical I Pam
don't work in cloud so one reason for
that is one feet when feature of an eye
Pam is a mapping of IP address to DNS to
the DNS servers right and that is done
automatically and recipe so in that
sense I mean we are doing already I mean
a big feature from - hi Pam right so
Ally Pam for cloud need to be very
different from an iPad that could be
used on Pam one we could for Patrick
here so I know that you have a tool to
manage your security right
do you mind discussing about that and
why you had to build the tool in the
first place sure I think so you're
talking about a lot about I Pam in terms
of managing individual addresses right
and this gentleman was talking about how
he's actually managing it like the
subnet level so one of the things we're
getting really heavy end on is using
kubernetes on share V PC which means has
IP aliasing which means I've got three
subnets per kubernetes cluster plus
Google and we're doing private clusters
so then Google picks a fourth range that
they're gonna appear in and then if
you're on internal IP space things like
cloud sequel it seems like there's a lot
of peering so it's on if it's more of a
comment than a question it feels like
there's still an IP space because my
spreadsheets pretty big but it's subnets
yeah it's really trying to manage
assignment because I'll have four to
five sub that's just for kubernetes
cluster and keeping track and some of
these are like peered spaced can't
overlap and Google Reserve's like some
of the 172 space for its peering that's
magic a tool I think would still help to
manage
that level of stuff because that itself
is starting to feel like it's gonna get
overwhelming right I think that that's
this is something that I was that I was
going to bring up the the the use of IP
addresses in kubernetes is is it's an
area that we get a lot of a lot of
concern about right and I would
recommend that anyone who's concerned
with that topic should go there's a talk
over at the Palace Hotel today at 11:40
I believe that's Enterprise kubernetes
I'd highly encourage you to go watch
that if you can't make it over there
just find the YouTube video after the
conference because they're gonna they're
gonna be talking about some things we're
introducing some concepts like custom
mode kubernetes IP addressing and so to
a certain extent when you build a when
you build your GAE cluster you're
getting the auto mode treatment right
and we recognize that that's not exactly
you know we did custom mode in V PC for
a reason we felt like okay well it's
probably it's probably about time we did
custom mode for gke as well and so
there's there's gonna be some more
information about that but at a higher
level some of the things that that
happens every time every pod gets its
own slash 24 right we found that there
there the nominal number of pods per
machine hour per node is usually around
8 and so a slash 24 is a little
excessive so we want to we want to be
able to - more or less right size that
so we're adding some features for that
and there's a lot more information about
that today at that Enterprise kubernetes
yeah so so I guess that's been one of
our biggest challenge we have a
development team that went in with gke
and we kind of told well ok we'll let
you do this and then all of a sudden
they decide to do 10.0.0.0 slash 14
which is pretty much the rest of our
enterprise and yeah god I had us do some
trickery with VPN to not propagate that
stuff down to kind of give some
segmentation but I know like for example
you there's IP masquerade
and but that kind of goes almost
completely against everything that
kubernetes does because I remember
talking to him it's like get one
scheanette and they were like we don't
want any so I start kicking around the
ideas is there I know this is the big
no-no for all the people in here or do
an IP but ipv6 because we're gonna we're
gonna hold that topic to the today okay
so I I have a lot to say about that okay
hopefully hopefully a lot to say about
that but yeah I do think ipv6 ism is
important let let's hear about Patrick's
tool real quick so I so during all of
that when we were converting from Kyle
to where we are now I'm so the one of
the things that we found there were a
lot of times we wanted to talk to things
outside and there wasn't a great way to
control the firewall rule management so
like we're big fastly customers being
able to take fast these ranges and say
these 50 extending our explicit security
behaviors to the edge we want only these
in ranges to talk to these five origin
servers or this group of origin servers
or this gke cluster and if we extended
it further we wanted to be able to say
when a gke cluster comes up it can speak
to this database server and so we built
what for all intents and purposes like a
firewall rule convergence tool so it
watches all of these sort of the
infrastructures our AWS stuff rgk gzp
stuff our fastly stuff and it is a
config file that converges into API
driven firewall rules so it'll go and
say oh I see a new instance within a
minute it it catches the event
it creates the firewall rule updates all
of the ones it needs to and so we're
able to dynamically generate firewall
rule so when we talk about explicit
security if I was doing it all by hand
like it just wouldn't happen engineers
are lazy we're that that's why we're
engineers and so it's we call a border
guard we're gonna be open sourcing it at
some point
but it allows us to create to eat to
care even less about IP addressing
because we really care about entity
security and so some of the things we
could easily do with service account
we can enter enter application or inter
virtual machine communication but as
soon as we extend past what is a VPC
boundary or past what is a project
boundary those tend to start to stop
being viable for us yeah I think so
just to kind of summarize this topic I
think with with cloud and when we when
we start talking about infrastructure as
code right we have to we have to be able
to manage IP addresses more based on
intent right then on then on strict
policy that is enforced by humans right
and so what Patrick's team has done is
they've they've been building this tool
for a while to automate all that and as
he said you're not going to be able to
get to this level of the explicit trust
in without an infrastructure as a code
as code model there's there's just no
way that you're gonna get there
so we're also you know things might look
bad to a certain extent but also given
the fact that we're opening API is to to
be able to automate our infrastructure
nowadays we are actually getting to a
place where we where we can do more
better faster and stay more on top of
what's going on I think my answer to
Olivia is objection about the cloud I
Pam not dealing with you know maybe DNS
or the DHCP stuff that you may not have
as much control over in cloud is that I
actually still I look at IP address
management less as a product and more as
a set of features or a set of functions
and and those are things that roll out
as API is over time and so you know this
is and those api's will facilitate the
kind of tools that Patrick is putting
together if you are on the explicit
explicit security model with IP address
management I would encourage you to look
at their tool and you know watch this
space I think it's called border guard
is the tool that they're that they're
building and it'll be open source at
some point correct yep it also has a
really neat feature
again engineering autonomy one of my
engineers got a little annoyed with
finding random firewall rules popping up
because the explicit security makes
people's lives a little more difficult
and so now it has new code it will go
through all the rules and be like I
don't know about these deleted which
helps okay we're gonna shift gears one
more time and talk about public IP
addresses it's it's not as controversial
a topic in a lot of in a lot of cases
because for enterprises the public IP
address is primarily used to go fetch
you know updates to your operating
system security security rules or
updates and maybe maybe package
management but for for companies like
bitly for companies like Vimeo where you
have a strong public facing port part of
your business the public IP address
becomes becomes also very important so
I'm sure Kyle has some thoughts on this
so bittley's technology relies upon DNS
which is arguably the most advanced
protocol that's ever been made on the
internet so we are basically held
hostage by the IP addresses that we've
been using since 2008 we have one Class
C we point every customer domain we have
thousands of customers tens of thousands
of customer domains all pointed to two
IP addresses so we are stuck in Colo
providers and much more antiquated
systems where they will still allow us
to bring those IP addresses within their
system do our BGP advertisements
etcetera so we have been leveraging and
hoping that there is some form of
allowing us to bring our IP addresses to
a cloud provider soon I'm gonna just
bump over to Jeremy on that we really
want that and that's a game changer for
us because if we can bring our IPS then
we could actually do things like go to
the cloud other than just be our
back-end services where we still have
this long string of network traffic
that's gonna go get data we want it to
go right into the cloud and we can't go
to you know 10,000 customers and say hey
pretty please change those two IP
addresses in your DNS a records come on
over that's a that's a nightmare nobody
wants to do that and so being able to
manage that public space within a cloud
provider is critical for us and it's
something that we're
hopefully looking forward to soon yeah
so he's ribbing me a little bit this is
a this is a feature that we get asked
for a lot and it's something that we've
been working on obviously the
infrastructure at Google is is very
complex and you know just just being
able to bring in foreign IP addresses
into our system and and leverage
leverage our connectivity to our peers
is it's both incredibly compelling and
also incredibly difficult so I would say
you know again watch this space I think
I think this is something that we have
been working on we have a we have I hear
every day a new use case for this for
this functionality so it's clear that
there needs to be an answer in a lot of
cases you know we've got we've got
customers like like bitly who have a
single or a few very very well-known IP
addresses and you know calling a
maintenance or a flag day and saying hey
we're gonna change everything to a cloud
IP address is probably a non-starter
we're also we're also in a world where
we're multi-cloud now and I don't even
know what that means for for maintaining
an autonomy over your own IP addresses
but it's another thing that we need to
think about we've we've even had some
surprising use cases I think where where
traditional enterprises might have
supply chain or EDI connectivity to
other partners in some cases thousands
of other partners where those are again
IP addresses that public IP addresses
that are well known by their partners
and you know it's something that they
can't put their business at risk on
trying to change those IP addresses and
I can relate one more story I had at a
company I used to work for we had some
manufacturing problems due to IP
addresses it turned out that there was
there were some certificates built into
the manufacturing process that required
that required a specific host on a
specific IP address that was in a Colo
provider that we no longer had a
relationship with so these are things
that I think we all probably have an
issue like this someplace and if you
look into your infrastructure there's
probably someone who knows about it
and you know through heroic intervention
has has you know kind of solved some
problems but these are things that again
with all of this we need to automate we
need to we need to we need to build
networks based on intent and we need to
eliminate the need for heroic
intervention to keep our business is
running I won't know if it's useful
something like this is useful for Phoebe
as well we put it we put everything
behind a CDN so for the most part like
we're really lucky nobody has any you
need to pin our stuff so first time in
my career I've just been able to say
like hey CBN's problem so what public
addressing is important for people to be
able to get to us it's not a identity
for us on the internet we regularly spin
up additional CD ends and move stuff
around and so it gives us a lot of
flexibility there are one or two things
on our network that where we have
sustained TCP connections that require
non CDN paths but those are we handle
those through other means and they're
not
IP address identity bound problems add
one thing here - does anyone in the
crowd like have that IP lock problem is
that a common thing I'm I'm asking
generally because we don't get exposure
to lot people that are like that
so kind of folks yeah yeah a good chunk
so more than I expected makes me feel a
little better one thing I will say about
this is and I'm gonna I'm gonna bring
this up you may not like that I'm doing
this but like AWS announced last week
that they're doing BYO IP right and I
freaked out about that a little bit cuz
I was like oh my god that's the thing I
want but there's a certain advantage in
GCPs environment to being globally aware
right away the fact that if we're able
to bring an IP address in or if we could
move to a Google IP now we get global
availability of that IP address right
away it's out of the box and it works
with everything right now
AWS is does not its region-locked
so it basically moves us from one Colo
to another Colo and doesn't really give
us the much disaster recovery doesn't
give us much
hot-hot capability to run multiple data
centers in order to run the same hot
data all over the world to lower
worldwide latency so just some
considerations to think about if you are
in that IP lock scenario and you're
looking for you know the little things
that you may not be thinking about right
now about what that means to move that
IP address around because it's it's nuts
is it a road map item for google I'd say
yes it's a road map item for Google yes
so the question was is it a road map
item for Google Jeremy into that and
then how subtle was I trying to be like
like 50 on a scale of 100 subtle this is
what my goal was here I'm just saying
that like you got really far down the
road in a lot of different places and
realized at the last minute like oh this
this really is just a lateral move for
us it's not a it's not a feature ad and
feature ad is what moving to the clouds
all about right like I can look at every
database I have and every big data
application I have and say gosh when I
moved to the cloud things should be so
much better and the same kind of goes
with IP addresses if you start looking
around but there's things to just think
about in that so global is better global
is better so we've got a question go to
the mic because oh
[Music]
yes so the question is multiple public
IP addresses per VM instance that's also
a road map item I'm working on it
so if you want to find me afterwards we
can talk about it so we're gonna run out
of time and I want to talk about ipv6 so
so but before before we completely run
out of time everyone that is currently
running ipv6 on your network raise your
hand okay so a quarter of the crowd
that's that's excellent that's better
than normal it means we're making some
progress of the folks in the crowd how
many how many plan to be running ipv6 on
their network within the next year keep
your hands up two years three years okay
so that's still that's still a little
bleak I I'm hearing we need to and oh
when we need to I see yeah so it turns
out this is this is a very very common
problem with v6 and so I I have I have
two comments to make about it first of
all we think that we've solved most of
the problem for folks who need public v6
with our global load balancers support
for v6 we do recognize that we need to
bring that to the to the network load
balancer as well but that would cover
off the most of the public access to v6
addresses that we need what I think is
kind of shocking and interesting and it
really relates to this conversation that
we've been having about internal IP
addresses or private IP addresses is
that there are a vast number of
enterprises who are just out of IP
address space they're out of RFC an IP
and age space 1918 space I see a hand I
see a couple hands more hands whoa
they're happening and and that happens
for a lot of reasons right it happens
because you have you have a lot of
growth it happens because you allocated
IP addresses fairly liberally early on
and now you're dealing with a 10 or 20
year old IP address IP allocation policy
it also happens through acquisitions
right and so to solve this we get a lot
of requests we get requests too so
for non RFC 1918 space addresses and in
in our cloud that is also something that
were that we're working on that will be
available but the the real answer to
this is a move to v6 and a move to b6
is it stuff right and it requires for an
enterprise to really embrace this I I've
got a couple of customers that I talked
to you frequently who are out of out of
1918 space they would like to move to v6
but their one department in a group of
many many departments and the other
teams that they need to that they need
to talk to would not be as eager to move
to v6 so they might not be technology
teams that can that can take that that
handoff so we're hoping to lead it in
the cloud and what what we plan to do is
really focus on the enterprise use case
of the internal use cases for v6 and so
that's things like VM to VM
communication which you which you won't
find on other clouds talking v6 VM to VM
VM with internal load balancers and and
also the ability to talk back to your
premise / / v6 be a dedicated
interconnect partner interconnect or or
over a VPN so that's the stuff that
we're working on I see a hand
yeah so the question is I love this
question you've set me up perfectly so
the question is are we are we willing to
consider a v6 gateway or 6to4 NAT that
would enable you to run v6 in cloud and
and and not worry about what other folks
are running and I think that's from my
perspective that's the right approach I
would rather take an approach where so
results II are I want to call him our
CTO because that's what he feels like to
us but he's the SVP of infrastructure
and the way he talks about this is the
problem with v6 is that it basically
introduced a new API without getting rid
of the old API right and that's not how
we do things right in every other in
every other part of development or
operations management you don't just let
two api's hang around at the same time
and so what I'd like to do I don't know
if we'll be successful but with customer
support we could do this what I'd like
to do is to offer a v6 only option with
these kinds of gateways so that so that
when you switch you only have to deal
with one IP address family you don't
have to worry worry about both you don't
have to worry about securing v4 and v6
you don't have to worry about you know
these label abstractions etc with v4 and
v6 and if we just always do dual stack
you're always going to have a v4 problem
right and if you've already got a v4
problem just by simply adding v6 I'm
just adding to it I'm not actually
solving so I hope that answers
yeah so the comment is that that be due
to the ephemeral nature of most of these
cloud assets it might actually just make
more sense to fully cut over yeah yes so
there's a question about extra bits and
what you could do with those bits so
interesting thing about v6 and an
another area where IP addresses weren't
built for clouds most of you who have
been running v6 are accustomed to using
things like stateless address
auto-configuration or slack and that
means that you're burning a slash 64 you
have you have 64 bits that are basically
reserved for the hosts to come up with
you know its unique identifier this is
completely unnecessary that was that was
built it was actually a transition
mechanism and this because we have
multiple api's in our cloud we're not
going to do slack we're gonna do DHCP
you're going to get IP addresses in that
way or you're going to statically assign
them and so the the thinking on this is
okay you don't need 64 bits really come
on right but we could still offer you
some bits to play with and so what if we
what if we gave you a slash 96 per host
if you add a slash 96 per host you have
32 bits that you can you can manipulate
to your heart's desire that's 32 bits
that's the size of today's internet on
every host right so you could use that
too you could use those bits completely
on your own to encode whatever you know
process ID or service ID or anything
anything like that and still preserve
the very lowest order bits for your host
for your host identifier so suddenly you
get this ID the same benefit of this
tuple of an IP address and a tag all
within an IP address and so this this is
a this is an area that I think you know
this isn't probably something that the
cloud is going to solve for you
but it would be good I think if we start
thinking about especially folks who are
ipv6 practitioners thinking about v6 for
cloud not v6 for Internet service
providers or v6 for remote enterprises
or
v6 for tunneling Jamie so perhaps we can
ask quickly
I mean how important is b6 for for both
of you I want v4 and v6 at the edge
whatever an internally is not hugely
important to me our infrastructure is
not big enough where v6 is a requirement
and we've yet to have one customer come
to us and demand quad a records or
anything like that so for us we provide
300 once a ton of benefit for HTTPS or
you know four four p v6 in that aspect
all right well I want to first of all
thank you all for showing up at 9:00
a.m. on the last day of the of the
conference
[Music]